slayer is an unsurpassed master of  scouting and diversion a whole dynasty  of assassins has honed their skills over  millennia  armed with shurikens and change towards  the Slayer has a variety of tricks up  their sleeve to surprise any opponent  Slayers like to play dirty using smoke  grenades to momentarily disorient foes  and turn the tide cloaking lets the  Slayer hide from hostile forces and  allows the use of Twilight shackle  rendering the enemy nearly motionless  and opening them up for deadly strikes  no foe can withstand the Slayers  relentless flurry uploads spiral through  the opposition with flight of the shadow  and use Twilight scourge to nullify  their chances of survival  slayer is a class for those who prefer  stealth and swift action over raw  unbridled fury use your unparalleled  sneaky to get a drop on enemies and  silently neutralize them in an instant  learn more at Skyforge calm  you